yesterday President Trump said the
Paycheck protection program one of the
federal initiatives designed to help
small businesses stay afloat processed
more than three billion dollars worth of
loans but as business owners apply to
the programs some have run into a
disturbing technical glitch Jim Axelrod
has the story
Eric Levinson put everything he had and
is starting the hummingbird in the pet
friendly bed-and-breakfast he opened in
Maryland in 2017 things were good until
coronavirus forced Levinson to close his
doors to go from a steady cash inflow
that you know obviously ebbs and flows
during the year to completely flatlining
no new reservations no new bookings so
no income at all Levinson turned to the
Small Business Administration or the SBA
for a disaster loan he went online and
opened the registration page and found
someone else's personal information name
address everything should have been
blank
had someone else's information in it
already correct date of birth social
security number email phone numbers
business address all the basic
information he deleted that information
and typed in his own ten minutes later
Levinson got a call from a business in
Delaware that had all of his information
you go on the computer and there's
someone else's information in the
application and then you get a call from
someone you've never met before and your
information all right he's on her
application correct what a mess I know
so on top of the stress I have trying to
keep this business going now I don't
know who else could have seen that
information Levinson isn't alone nearly
a dozen other small businesses across
the country told CBS News they
experienced the same problem last week
this couldn't come at a worse time for
small businesses according to Todd
McCracken with the National Small
Business Association they've gotten
assistance is coming that they can can
on those horses and these kinds of
wishes happen it really undercuts their
confidence in the system and Mike needs
me to make different decisions they
would have otherwise the SBA's website
went through various shutdowns for
maintenance last week but the agency
told CBS News this site is currently
working that comforting to you on the
site sense it's not comforting to me I
have no choice
Levinson says he tried emailing tweeting
even attending an online SBA a webinar
to alert them to the problem he hasn't
heard anything back the SBA is yet to
even acknowledge the leaks say for how
long they had the problem or even the
number of businesses that may have been
impacted for CBS this morning Saturday
this is Jim Axelrod in Montclair New
Jersey